the story of the manager was that I was
in a writing group and there were some
professional writers there's actually
Academy Award nominated writer we met at
her house so I was really exciting and
I'd written a script they were giving me
feedback and long story short it got to
the point where they're like this
scripts amazing
this script will sell the only question
is how much it will sell for do you want
help getting an agent and of course that
was like magic to my ears and then I
mentioned this to my professor at UCLA
who you know a lot of really big writers
had come through that school and through
his class and so he volunteered to read
the script and he this is one of the
three best scripts I've ever read in 20
years at UCLA and again I'm thinking of
all these amazing writers but so I'm
like well I guess I'm as good as those
and he goes this will definitely sell
you want help in getting the manager an
agent and I was interning for a manager
at the time as an intern so as a favor
as a favor to that manager I'm like do
you want to read this because I like
it's going to sell and see what do you
want your 10% or not buddy and so he
agreed to read it took like three weeks
which told me crazy and then we had a
meeting I'll never forget I go in there
and he's like this is a pretty good
rough draft don't show it to in the
industry because when you show stuff to
people industry they get coverage
reports on it and those are database
that's your first impression but if it's
not great coverage you haven't just
blown your chances at that production
company they're going to share that
coverage with everybody so database so
you you blown your first impression
across the board and he said this will
not serve you well but you have some
real strengths you have some real
weaknesses you have you know some blind
spots I could help you with that if
you're giving me this whole talk and the
whole time I'm like what is wrong with
him and like did I tell you what they
can't you weren't nominated persons I
sent my professor who represented
Stevens or you know top Stevens
it wasn't way anyway you know and he
said look they were all telling you the
truth this was a better script in most
scripts it's an impressive script but
it's not nearly as good as what you need
in the industry you look your people are
writing group are working writers your
professor at UCLA all smart people but
they're not in the business of breaking
writers into the business
am i know how good something has to be
this isn't close and I'm like didn't
want to believe that my six mindsets
like heal an idiot and so what he said
and all this was the best thing anybody
could have said is hire three studio
readers pay them under the table
if this script came through the tracking
system what coverage would you write and
then give me the coverage the honest
coverage and the coverage isn't good
it's not going to hurt you because it's
just you only see it nobody else sees it
and I didn't have a lot of money but I
did this I paid him like 100 hundred
fifty bucks three different people
someone had imagined someone at Warner
Brothers and so when it Scott Rudin's
company and the coverage came back and
it wasn't terrible and it wasn't bad it
was okay which is terrible it would have
hurt me it was clear that his coverage
was like this is okay not being special
nothing great here and then on the
writer it says you know recommend
consider it was low marks on the writing
on two of the three and that you can't
hide from that and then the manager said
I'll work with you if you're willing to
put your ego at the door and do this
training so I did it was like 14 months
it was grueling he was he was not a good
person but that his training was good it
was it was marine it was much rougher
than it had to be but okay and at the
end of that time he said I now think the
script is where it needs to be all pay
for coverage reports and he paid for
three coverage reports of three
different people real actual readers and
it was all just exactly what you want
exceptional coverage and literally three
weeks later Ridley Scott hires me to
write metropolis
flies me to London I mean like my whole
world changed my whole life changed and
it never would have happened if that
manager hadn't sort of forced me to pay
for coverage and so because at some
point it takes mindset can hide and
that's what I always tell people if
you're thinking like the biggest mistake
you can make is go out to the
marketplace before
already and just because your friends
think it's great and just because your
teacher thinks it's great and just two
guys the script consultant you hired is
great and I I don't do anymore I used to
do script consulting but I say don't
listen to those people because they
often they're running a business in a
business one's happy repeat customers so
they often tell you what you want to
hear and even if you find the script
consultant has incredible integrity
which is rare but they exist they're not
in the business of breaking writers into
the business and and I wouldn't listen
to their advice per se I know people who
are like I had the script consultant
said this this and this I went on to the
marketplace look at the coverage it
stunk it happens all the time
I say hire actual readers under the
table in TV or future wherever you are
and get the actual coverage report that
they would get and if all three coverage
reports come back recommend recommend
highest marks then you're ready to go up
then then yeah get on the highest
mountain pound your chest and get
everybody to read your script if that's
not the case
stay off the radar you don't want people
reading your material it's going to hurt
you and figure out how you can train
yourself to get better so sorry for a
long answer but no I was very fixed
mindset and if that Manager hadn't done
that for me I'd be taking classes a day
I wouldn't be teaching them
you